>> ♪ ♪
>> Laura: SUCH GREAT NEWS.
MITCH MCCONNELL BOLDLY CANCELLED
MOST OF THE AUGUST RECESS.
HE WANTS CONGRESS TO WORK.
CONFIRMED LONG STALLED
NOMINATIONS.
I SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT THOSE
ISSUES IN IN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
A SHORT WHILE AGO.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Laura: THE BIG AUGUST RECESS,
TELL ME ABOUT THIS.
CHUCK SCHUMER IS FINE WITH AS
LONG AS THEY SPEND TIME ON
HEALTH CARE VOTES.
>> WELL, WE WILL BE CONFIRMING
THE PRESIDENT'S NOMINEES.
WE HAD TO FILE CLOSURE TO SPEED
THE PROCESS UP 101 TIMES DURING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ADMINISTRATION
TO SPEED UP THE CONFIRMATION OF
HIS APPOINTMENTS.
THAT HAPPENED ONLY 24 TIMES OVER
THE LAST 6 PRESIDENTS.
THEY MADE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
CONFIRM JUDGES AS WELL.
EVEN THOUGH WE WIN THEM ALL,
THEY ARE TAKING TIME.
I WILL GIVE THEM PLENTY OF TIME.
>> Laura: CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
DEMOCRATS HAVE A GOOD CHANCE OF
TAKING THE SENATE.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT WILL BE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
OFF YEAR ELECTIONS 2 YEARS INTO
ANY PRESIDENT.
BILL CLINTON LOST THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
OBAMA LOST THE HOUSE AND ALMOST
LOST THE SENATE.
IT WILL BE A KNOCK DOWN, DRAG
OUT FIGHT.
WE ARE OPTIMISTIC WE WILL STILL
HAVE THE MAJORITY AND CONFIRM
THE PRESIDENT'S APPOINTMENTS.
IF WE LOSE THE SENATE, ON
APPOINTMENTS TO THE CABINET AND
ALL OF THAT, I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONQUENCES FOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION IF WE LOSE
THE SENATE.
>> Laura: OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
ECONOMY IN THE FUTURE?
>> YES, THE ECONOMY IS ROARING.
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN DECADES.
JOBS ARE CREATED.
MUCH ATTRIBUTEED TO THE TAX CUTS
BILL PASS THE LAST DECEMBER.
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO BE AN
AMERICAN LOOKING FOR WORK.
>> Laura: WHY WOULD PEOPLE VOTE
AGAINST THEIR OWN POCKETBOOKS?
>> THAT'S OUR ARGUMENT AND THEY
HOPE THEY SHARE OUR VIEW.
THIS IS NOT AN ENVIRONMENT
CRYING OUT FOR CHANGE.
>> Laura: REPUBLICAN DONORS SAID
UNLESS CONGRESS PASSES THE DACA
AMNESTY, THEY WON'T GIVE A
PENNY.
ANY POSSIBILITY OF IMMIGRATION
REFORM GETTING PASSED IN THE
HOUSE AND THEN THE SENATE?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT IN THE
HOUSE.
I WENT TO IMMIGRATION EARLY THIS
YEAR.
WIDE OPEN FOR AMENDMENTS.
THE SENATE DIDN'T WANT TO PASS
ANY PARTICULAR VERSION OF IT.
I CAN'T SEE US GOING BACK TO
IMMIGRATION THIS YEAR UNLESS
THERE WAS SOME PROPOSAL THE
PRESIDENT IS WILLING TO SIGN.
I DON'T THINK HE IS ANYTHING
WITH ANYTHING I AM SEEING.
SHORT ANSWER NOT ON THE AGENDA
IN THE SENATE.
>> Laura: BOB CORKER AND OTHERS
EXPRESSED THEIR DISMAY OVER THE
PRESIDENT'S TARIFFS.
THE PRESIDENT WON ON THIS ROBUST
ECONOMIC NATIONAL PLATFORM.
GOOD FOR THE SENATE TO TAKE ON
THE PRESIDENT ON THE ISSUE OF
TARIFFS?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I AM NOT THRILLED ABOUT THE
TARIFFS, BUT WE WON'T BE PASSING
SOMETHING THAT THE PRESIDENT CAN
LEGALLY DO.
>> Laura: THE IG REPORT THAT WAS
DELAYED AND IS COMING OUT HAS
LEAKED PARTS OF IT SAYING THAT
JIM COMEY THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR WAS INSUBORDINATE AND
DEFIED AUTHORITY IN THE WAY HE
HANDLED HIS JOB.
AT THE END HE NOTIFIED CONGRESS
AND CITED LORETTA LYNCH.
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT GIVEN --
>> WE ARE ANXIOUS TO SEE WHAT
HIS RECOMMENDATION WILL BE.
WE HEARD HE IS A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER.
WE KNOW HE IS CONDUCTING THIS
INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE NOT HEARD ABOUT THE
LEAKS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIS REPORT.
I HOPE IT COMES OUT SOON.
>> Laura: THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI ANDREW McCABE'S LAWYERS
IS ASKING FOR IMMUNITY BEFORE HE
TESTIFIES BEFORE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE HEADED BY CHUCK
GRASSLEY.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> THAT'S CERTAINLY INTERESTING.
YOU COULD IMPLY WHAT YOU CHOOSE
TO IMPLAY FROM THAT SORT OF
THING.
YOU ARE A LAWYER.
I THINK IT'S AN INTERESTING
REQUEST.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PEOPLE SAID
DONALD TRUMP IS CALLING THE FBI
INTO QUESTION.
HOW DARE HE QUESTION THE FBI.
WE LOVE THE FBI BUT THIS IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI AND THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
>> I THINK ALL OF THESE THINGS
WILL COME OUT SOONER OR LATER.
THE IG REPORT IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE INTERESTING.
>> Laura: THE BIG QUESTION FOR
ALL OF US COURT WATCHERS IS THE
SUPREME COURT.
THE DECISION COMING OUT KENNEDY
AND THE MAJORITY.
THE BAKERY CASE THIS WEEK.
IF KENNEDY STEPS DOWN AND
RETIRES, WHEN WILL THE SUPREME
COURT HEARINGS BE HELD GIVEN THE
TIGHT SCHEDULE WE ALREADY HAVE?
>> THE CONGRESS MEETS UNTIL
DECEMBER 31st THIS YEAR.
IF WE GET A VACANCY IN THE NEXT
MONTH OR TWO WE WILL DEAL WITH
IT THIS YEAR.
>> Laura: BEFORE THE NEW COURT
TERM BEGINS?
>> IT WILL BE HELD THIS YEAR.
IF THERE IS A VACANCY IN THE
NEXT MONTH OR TWO, WE HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME TO DO THE
CONFIRMATION.
>> Laura: ANY SENSE THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NARROWED DOWN THE
CANDIDATES TO 1 OR 2 PEOPLE?
>> I CAN'T IMAGINE THEY ARE NOT
BEING ABOUT THIS.
I BELIEVE THEY ARE.
IF A VACANCY OCCURS WE GET A
NOMINATION QUICKLY AND DEAL
WITH.
IT'S NOT JUST THE SUPREME COURT.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED 21 CIRCUIT
COURT JUDGES IN THE FIRST YEAR
AND A HALF OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BREAKING ALL RECORDS.
ONE 8th OF THE CIRCUIT JUDGES
HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED IN A YEAR
AND A HALF.
>> Laura: 8 STILL WAITING TO GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE?
>> THEY WILL ALL BE DONE THIS
YEAR.
>> Laura: YOU HOPE TO GET THEM
DONE THROUGH THE AUGUST RECESS?
>> THIS YEAR.
>> Laura: THIS IS THE
ANNIVERSARY OF D-DAY.
HAVE YOU SPENT TIME WITH
VETERANS INVESTIGATE WASHINGTON.
-- VISITING WASHINGTON.
>> MY DAD WAS IN WORLD WAR II IN
GERMANY.
HE GOT THERE AFTER D-DAY.
IT WAS THE GREATEST GENERATION.
ONE FELLOW TODAY WAS 100 YEARS
OLD.
HE WAS IN THE ORIGINAL NORTH
AFRICA INVASION AND THERE WITH
THE GERMANS SURRENDERED.